[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola qué tal
en estas dos fotos yo tenía cuatro y
cinco años estaba buscando uno de seis
años pero lamentablemente no lo encontré
porque seis añitos hace 20 años
exactamente yo tenía 6 años y cursaba el
primer grado de primaria
me pasó algo super curioso que y siento
que me marcó muchísimo hasta ahora
[Música]
cuando yo estaba en primer grado de
primaria como toda niña feliz siempre
buscaba sacar la menor notas hoy
en la penúltima de seis hermanos
entonces era como la empleada de papá un
día saqué 20 y phil feliz a mi casa papá
papá tengo 20 y yo no sé es el momento
que pasó por la cabeza de mi papá y me
dijo hija pero en mi tiempo yo sacaba 21
y yo me quedé como
pero la máxima nota no 21 seis anillos
de tenis
al siguiente examen creo que inicial
la mayoría buscamos sacar 20 regrese una
extra de matemáticas y donde la
profesora volvió a sacar 20 leyó
profesora el papá dice que la máxima
nota es 21 en que he fallado porque me
ha puesto sólo bello yo quiero invertir
la profesora sandra todo está bien bueno
yo no sé cómo la convencí la verdad esa
parte ya no recuerdo
[Música]
y en mi casa más feliz creo que mi casa
quedaba super cerca al colegio llegué en
dos minutos y feliz papá ya que decir
121 mil hectáreas y papá como que de
asombro y medias de medio feliz y me
dijo esa es mi hija
y yo me feliz seis añitos me compro todo
lo que quería y me feliz en ese momento
después de 20 años yo me puedo dar
cuenta ahora de ese 21 me trajo dos
enseñanzas dos enseñanzas grandes una
que desde muy pequeña me preocupaba por
hacer las cosas bien por querer ser la
mejor hija la mejor alumna la mejor
estudiante la mejor la mejor la mejor la
mejor eso
y estaba buscando cumplir todas las
expectativas para ser feliz a mi papá
para ser feliz a la gente que me rodeaba
pero no me había dado cuenta que no
estaba siendo feliz yo y lo otro es que
ese 21 me enseñó de verdad una nota no
nos define
nosotros vamos a caer 11 0 12 20 o 21
como en mi caso pero eso no es lo que
nos define realmente en esta vida no hay
límites no hay un techo y eso de verdad
va a depender muchísimo solo de nosotros
hasta dónde queremos llegar si nos
queremos quedar con ese 20 hoy como yo
por eso quiero
yo crecí en ese permito durante 16 años
a tres horas de la ciudad de guárico
luego llegó el gran día
el colegio se acaba y venía la pregunta
del millón como muchos para nosotros se
termina el colegio y ahora sandra
que continúan qué carrera vas a estudiar
de hecho yo no tuve que decidir mucho
desde pequeña imagínense ti papá
pidiéndome el 21 era como la hacienda
viva que me molestaba todos los números
de teléfono ya ya mi papá me dijo hija
tú vas a estudiar ingeniería civil
verdad es como si vas a estudiar porque
sí y efectivamente yo terminé el colegio
me fui a la ciudad y en cuanto me
preparé para postular ingeniería civil
llegué
llegó el primer día del examen de
admisión
y no iris
y no me sentía tan mal estaba normal y
me volví a preparar fui el segundo a la
segunda admisión llegue a la segunda
adquisición y es el momento algo se
cruzó en mi cabeza
porque yo sentía que esa carrera y yo
todo lo había elegido y decidí cambiar y
poner en ese entonces te permite a la
universidad poner dos opciones puse
ingeniería industrial que no sabía muy
bien que era sólo por darle la contra
esa segunda opción sí y que cree ingresé
a ingeniería industrial y con la nota
que había sacado en la segunda en el
segundo examen pude haber ingresado
ingeniería civil pero tomé la decisión
ese momento y desde ese momento yo me di
cuenta que yo podía tomar mis propias
decisiones y yo podía ir por los bellos
que yo quería no por lo que
influían al llegar básicamente a la
universidad
de verdad siempre estudiaba en un
colegio para este estatal fue un cambio
muy brusco en el primer ciclo de la
universidad de ingeniero industrial
reprobé más de un curso
[Música]
me sentí fatal porque yo estaba
acostumbrada a sacar 20 21 era lo mejor
de todo se imagina y no sabía cómo
decirles a mis papás pero siento que ese
fue el punto de inflexión para yo decir
y darme cuenta que realmente ya no
tendrían igual que el inicio una nota no
me tenía que definir si yo quería hacer
las cosas las tenía que hacer
simplemente por querer aprender desde
ese momento yo me prometí a mí misma
todas las cosas que voy a hacer y las
tengo que hacer van a ser para mí y para
servir a los demás
e
luego en la universidad
me alegré con los cursos
ya no volvía a reprobar más llegue a ser
egipto superior y cerquita superior me
ayudó y me abrió muchísimas formas y una
de ellas es participar en el cardio
universitario también me permitió hacer
un intercambio a católica donde estudié
todo el no menos siglo al regresar a
guárico y ya por el décimo ciclo
nuevamente cada día aparece en mi vida y
yo recuerdo claramente en el 2015 que
regresé acabé había un concurso que
habían lanzado que decía cómo te
comprometes tú
con tu para contribuir a que el país
mejore la propiedad
yo lo mandé esa fecha de hecho gracias
al 6 lo volví a leer ahora luego de 4
años y ese era el compromiso terror que
yo realizaba y volvía el cade
universitario por segunda vez me cambio
notable y volví para este calle me dio
muchísimas cosas me dio una familia de
embajadores y éste cae también me
involucro más en desarrollar proyectos y
emprendimientos para innovar irme fuera
de nuestro país
es así que ella revisándoles este cáliz
empezamos carlos y más talleres que más
podía haber y allí me encontré con esto
junto con 130 jóvenes de todo el país
reunidos en un oso y solo en un solo
lugar pudimos desarrollar ideas de
negocio y emprendimientos que tengan el
tribuno impacto hasta ese entonces yo no
sabía mucho que era emprendimientos que
tengan este impacto porque yo sin darme
cuenta de mi niñez ya había emprendido
por primera vez a los 11 desde los 11
años yo vendía quesos hechas por mí
misma las ordeñaba yo misma la huaca y
ahora que retrocedo y empleo el pasado
era un emprendimiento que ya ya nació en
[Música]
estoy estas actividades me llevaron a
comprometerme que yo tengo que
desarrollar algo que realmente es en el
impacto y que trascienda
no sabía hasta ese momento cuándo y
dónde es así que ya luego de salir de la
universidad con los años he decidido
enrutar e irme a colombia a hacer un
voluntariado ya venía trabajando lo dije
todo tenía un buen trabajo un buen
puesto estaba con mi familia abanico de
un método pero decidieron estudiar como
debe ser ya que esta visión hay un foro
y vaya que esta forma de salir de visto
la de confort iba a ser una labor social
y colombia advertirlos british
al regresar me pregunto ahora que
continúa porque ella al regresar no
tenía trabajo porque había renunciado y
el área decidió quedar en lima y
el té
otra vez cada universitario aparece en
mi vida
y me permite regresar como embajadora
del estadio universitario y éste carece
de toda la lectura división ya es como
en la tercera la vencida no saldrá ya le
vio hablando participando abrocha
charlas ahora con cada acción a él y te
cabe conocí a mi socia y justo con ella
decidimos ocupar un proyecto a la cual
ahora es nuestro día a día que
trabajamos 24/7 para sacarlo adelante y
acá quiero hacer una pausa y quiero que
él piense en la palabra en una palabra
que usted les venga a la mente cuatro
veces
[Música]
bueno
a muchos de nosotros tal vez reciclador
reciclar basura de ellos chatarreros hay
muchas palabras que se nos pueden venir
a la mente algunos de ustedes pensó en
emprendimiento o negocios
[Música]
junto con antonella nosotros vimos la
oportunidad que se podía hacer un cambio
que se pueda trascender en base a lo que
vimos al anterior
ella es la señora erika es madre no la
conocimos a erika trabajando
se dedica muchos años al reciclaje la
conocimos en el sótano de un edificio
donde nosotros buscábamos mayor
información de cuál era el rumbo de la
basura dónde terminaba cómo se
gestionaba y es así que nosotros
conocemos a él y acá al igual que el ica
esta es la realidad al igual que vemos a
personas en la calle caminando para
recuperar un pedazo de papel o pedazos a
poco se hace plástico las otras personas
que desarrollan esta gran labor porque
es así es una labor ardua que para
muchos de nosotros no significa nada
pero para ellos es su medio de vida
algunos están en los sótanos de los
edificios
de igual forma escarbando para recuperar
cierto tipo de material así como el y
casi como carles y muchos de los
recolectores en nuestro país tenemos 108
mil familias que se dedican al sistema
de reciclaje
ante esto y ante la poca cultura de
reciclaje que tenemos como peruanos nace
de contrario
el contrario es un emprendimiento
inclusivo que busca crear trabajo digno
para jóvenes y mujeres recolectores de
nuestro país a través de la tecnología
una lo mejor de la logística con la
tecnología permite conectar a personas
que tienen material reciclable con
nuestros líderes ambientales que
nosotros les llamamos hacia nuestros
colectores
echo atrás busca crear trabajo digno
pasa de que erika esté en el sótano y
vaya a las oficinas corporativas de las
empresas a recoger el material buscamos
concientizar también a las empresas ya
los usuarios que tenemos y esta foto me
gusta muchísimo porque echo atrás nació
aproximadamente hace un año y medio y yo
tenía 25 exactamente el 7 de mayo
yo creo que si nosotros queremos lograr
sueños grandes tenemos que empezar
temprano
muchas veces no nos damos cuenta para
que hemos venido acá no nos estamos a
preguntarnos ya hemos venido para
cumplir los sueños de nuestros papás que
mi hija quiere ser y era civil como en
mi caso hemos venido a esta vida para
cumplir
quería el efecto hemos venido para
nosotros ser felices y cumplir nuestro
propósito yo siento que en esta vida
todavía es muy grande y yo siento que ya
encontré el propósito mi forma de vivir
y es seguir trabajando día a día por
echo atrás y hoy quiero invitarlos por
favor a que encuentren su sueño y
propósito y que espero que todo lo que
le haya compartido 6-3 y variant y les
quiero dejar con este último mensaje si
deseamos si deseamos emprender en algo
en lo que sea derecho a los invito no a
emprender de pronto el mentalmente en un
emprendimiento que vaya a tener tres
triples pactos como en el caso de otras
enfrentamos y comprometa vamos con
nuestros sueños vez es el lugar donde
debe
donde nos encontremos seamos los mejores
colaboradores seamos el mejor yo y de
verdad el mejor emprendimiento que uno
puede desarrollar somos nosotros mismos
querer ser la versión mejorada de ti
mismo no imitar a ningunos y los invito
también que si encontramos un desafío
una problemática nos enamoremos de ella
y no de la solución muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]